[Musique]
bonsoir baratte en khâgne à merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france alors nous avons appris ce
soir une deux contaminations en france 1
c'est officiel est-ce que la situation
en europe vous inquiètent-elles je ne
sais le cours naturel des événements
dans de tels cas d'infection il y aura
des infections dans les pays d'origine
comme la chine puis et des cas dans
d'autres régions du monde
ce que nous devons faire c'est essayer
de limiter autant que possible le nombre
de cas c'est ce qu'on appelle confirmant
ainsi ce que nous faisons en ce moment
ça veut dire vraiment selon vous le
spécialiste médical que clairement les
autorités les pouvoirs publics et les
décisionnaires politiques finalement
aujourd'hui on la situation grandement
entre leurs mains c'était à eux de jouer
de prendre les bonnes décisions dans
chaque pays
je le pensais je
ce sont des problèmes compliqués il n'y
a jamais eu une réponse unique mais ce
qui est important c'est que nos actions
soient en mesure et menons des actions
de santé publique afin de protéger les
populations
mais il ne faut pas adopter des mesures
qui pourraient également leur nuire
quelles que soient les actions que nous
choisissons il faut réfléchir aux
avantages et aux inconvénients pour la
population il faut que l'action soit
scientifique bien informés et ensuite
que nous décidions et non pas dans
l'autre sens vous justement en tant que
responsable médical que médecin
qu'est-ce que vous attendriez
des pouvoirs publics on a vu que
certains et à fermer leurs frontières en
europe ya eu cette discussion mais ce
n'est pas le cas évidemment par
définition c'est compliqué de fermer une
frontière en europe mais vous iriez vers
ce genre de mesures éviter finalement
tant que faire se peut les les
déplacements entre les états touchés
non je pense que la décision de manière
à l'ouverture des frontières et la bonne
car fermer les frontières ne sert à rien
cela on voit au contraire à un message
mauvais et le bon message c'est que nous
devons coopérer faut que nous fassions
preuve de responsabilité sociale afin de
réduire le nombre des cargos inju la
série de ne pas se rendre dans un foyer
d'infection est pas non plus sortir de
ce foyer
si on aurait pu être infecté ainsi en
travers de concerts peut bien mieux s'en
tirer
c'est bien supérieur à l'idée de fermer
les frontières car cela ne permet pas
d'atteindre le résultat escompté
alors outre manche 1 chez vous dès le 19
février il était dit le coronavirus
arrêté je cite une menace grave et
imminente
est ce que on doit vraiment s'inquiéter
pourquoi cette maladie finalement fait
elle aussi peur c'est une très bonne
occasion de rassurer votre public
c'est la situation est préoccupante
parce que c'est un nouveau virus et que
certaines personnes tombent malades
mais mon message principal c'est que la
plupart des personnes selon infectés et
se remettront seules quelques personnes
auront besoin de consulter un médecin
et parmi ces quelques personnes qui
consulter un médecin
seules quelques-unes nombre très limité
auront besoin d'une hospitalisation et
certaines personnes seulement auront
besoin de soins intensifs
il faut remettre à la situation dans son
contexte
la plupart des personnes même si elles
sont infectées guériront et c'est un
message très important pour le public
nous ne voulons pas les inquiéter
inutilement car cela serait mal est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une étude sur le
profil des victimes
il ya eu évidemment plusieurs plus de
2000 morts en chine 1 je crois
d'autres morts ailleurs dans le monde
est ce qu'à un recul suffisant pour
savoir pour qui c'est dangereux et pour
qui ça l'est moins comme vous me l'avez
expliqué en somme toute étude cette idée
nomi depuis enrayer l'apparition de la
maladie
mi décembre en chine donc nous en
apprenons ce que nous savons et
calmement c'est que selon ce sont
surtout les personnes âgées qui sont
touchés et les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités comme des maladies
cardiaques du foie ou des reins nous
devons rester conscient du fait que
puisqu'il s'agit d'un homme virus
alors effectivement il peut attaquer
n'importe qui mais les personnes qui en
souffrent le plus sont les personnes
âgées qui ont déjà d'autres maladies
concomitante
donc je souhaite il faudrait plus
rassurer vos auditeurs des personnes
peuvent être infectés mais en règle
générale un pourcentage très petit de la
population sont plus touchés que
d'autres ont aussi beaucoup
d'inquiétudes évidemment pour les
parents pour leurs enfants notamment des
parents d'enfants asthmatiques y en a
beaucoup dans les grandes villes est ce
qu'on a là aussi du recul pour ces types
de profils est-ce que c'est plus
dangereux
et pour mieux nous n'avons pas tout à
fait cette information nous ne savons
pas ce qu'ils arrivent spécifiquement
aux enfants qui souffrent d'une
condition particulière notamment de la
simone mais la précaution en général le
conseil général c'est qu'il faut
maintenir des conditions d'hygiène bonne
évitez les endroits où il ya beaucoup de
monde et cela ne nous affectera pas si
vous êtes loin de quelqu'un car cela se
propage à proximité avec les
gouttelettes de salive
il faut donc se lavent éléments se laver
les mains avec de l'eau chaude et du
savon et il faut surtout se sécher les
mains des mains propres et sèches sont
très importantes pour éviter le
coronavirus de plus il faut se laver les
mains avant de manger et c'est un
message de santé publique très important
merci beaucoup en tout cas baratte
pagani un expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter de
nous avoir un petit peu rassuré nos
téléspectateurs en tout cas en direct
sur rt france au soir merci à vous